وقال الجيش الاوكراني ان قوته الجويه جنه
خلال ساعه الماضيه سبعه عشره غاره على
مواقع تمركز القوه الروسيه ومواقع
منظماتها الصاروخيه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه نفذت خلال اليوم الماضي
27 غاره اضافه الى 55 رشقه صاروخيه على
مواقع اوكرانيه لم تحددها واشارات الى ان
القوه الروسيه وصلت محاولتها الهجوميه في
اكثر من اتجاه هو انها قصفت اكثر من 15
منطقه في ذا فولوجيا ومناطق اخرى في خرسون
جنوبيه البلاد
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان تهديد
الروسيه بشان ضربات بالصواريخ الارضيه
والجويه والمسيرات لا يزال قائما في جميع
انحاء البلاد
الروسيه تشن ما سمتها هجمات فاشله على
محوري افدياد ولمن كما تواصل محاولتها في
محور البخمه شرقيه البلاد وذكره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه عن قواتها تصدت امس لها جامعه
الروسيه على عده
شرقيه البلاد